we'll pick back up on the business of
writing in just a little bit but we had
a comment
we received today on our youtube channel
and it is
the more movies are structured the more
movies will feel unoriginal
templates are fine if you don't mind to
be unoriginal
if you're an aspiring script writer and
you want to stand out from the crowd
you better come up with something fresh
something that doesn't follow quote the
rules
and still work as a compelling story
remember most stories
follow conventions real life doesn't so
if you want to create a compelling story
that is fresh and true to life
stay away from the conventions any
thoughts
well um i think
when you talk about uh conventions i
think there's two uh
two ways you can look at it you can look
at it as the
the the writers conventions in terms of
the story structure the beats the system
if any that you choose to follow but i
also think there are the audiences
conventions
and um in especially in independent
publishing
uh you you if you don't give the
audience what they want
they are not going to read your books
you know and i mean and i i think some
people might
you know they call it in the in in the
novel world they call it writing to
market
you know if you know this particular
niche wants
these things and some genres are much
stricter than others if you're writing
romance for example
there are very strict rules about you
know there are
happy ever after endings and there are
you know sad endings and you have to
tell the reader which one it is because
if they don't like sad endings they are
not going to like your book and
you know there are alpha male romances
and
nerdy guy romances and harem romances
where there's like one woman and
or one guy and multiple women and then
reverse harem romances where there's one
woman and multiple guys
and they they're very uh particular
about what they want
and so i think that you know
in for what i write in terms of spy
thrillers i don't think it's as
regimented as that but certainly if i am
selling my book as a action-packed spy
thriller
and you know there's the action doesn't
stand out or the action isn't exemplary
or
if i make a lot of factual errors and
present things that are just you know
physically impossible
uh if i get the weapons wrong you know
the audience is very
into the weapons you know if i say i
remember
i can't i might in tokyo black actually
in the first draft
i called the magazine which is what
holds the bullets a clip and i got
so many comments about how that's the
incorrect terminology so i actually
went back and republi you can one of the
good things about self-publishing is you
can always upload a new version of the
manuscript so i went in and changed all
those and put it back up
um you know those things are important
to the readers and i don't think it's
fair to
say that they shouldn't be or to say
that or rather i guess it's fair to say
if you're going to ignore those things
then
do so at you know know what you're doing
go into it with your eyes open and have
a reason for it
not just to break the convention you
know i mean if there's a point to it
it might work you know but if you're
just if you're just breaking what the
audience wants because you want to do
something else
you know the audience you're i write for
my audience they're the ones buying
my books you know um now in terms of the
structure on the writer's
side i do agr i agree and i disagree i
mean i think
i caught this this sounds very
pretentious but i think of structure as
i think of a story as analog and
structure as
digital in the sense that uh you know
digital video or digital audio
is sampling reality and to making it
sound real to your ear
with with less information you know
there's actually so like uh
the difference between a vhs and a dvd
is there's you know on a vhs there's an
infinite variation of color between you
know on the spectrum between
blue and green you know whereas on a dvd
at some point
it's digital it clips off and blue stops
and green starts
and it's just too small a gap for the
human eye to see you can't perceive it
and what i guess what i mean by that is
i think that
there's always a sort of inherent
structure to a story
but whether it follows these exact
beats that people have come up with over
the years you know whether you use
save the cat or the hero's journey
i think those are sort of just overlays
that we put on top of it to make sense
of it all and i think that you just need
to find
what works for you as a writer and
that's that's all the structure you need
in my opinion
so when you've gone back in to edit
things is it just little details that i
realized they
weren't little to the reader but you
weren't actually going back in
no yeah or you know sometimes they'll
catch a typo you know i mean
i do edit my books but even even in new
york times bestsellers if you really
look you'll find typos occasionally so
sometimes readers spot a typo and i'll
go in and correct that
but i never i've never drastically
altered the story or anything like that
and so i'm sure as your books have
progressed because you have how many out
now sorry
uh well i have two series i also have a
science fiction series but in the
the cane series i believe there's eight
nine eight or nine
and so the feedback that you've received
whether it's on amazon
or people have emailed you that helped
shape
the next sort of adventure that came to
some degree i mean yes or no
um i don't think i've never really
gotten
an email like uh you know you really
need the books to feel more like this
or if i have i haven't necessarily gone
in that route but uh
uh i do communicate with my readers and
some of them some some of them are
experts you know in weaponry there's i
have a lot of readers in the military
you know so i'll reach out to them with
questions like hey you know uh
the latest book which hasn't come out
yet is set in vietnam you know what are
what weapons would the vietnamese army
use you know a standard issue that he
could maybe get a hold of you know
things like that
um and uh you know i'll ask for feedback
or for information on those kinds of
areas like help with research
the third book was all set in sudan and
south sudan and so i asked some
readers who had traveled through africa
for some information there you know like
just things about the area that i
couldn't find through research
um you know little things like that and
this is all set in current times yes
okay for the most part i mean it's kind
of a vague timeline but they're not
you know they're not like world war ii
stories or anything it's meant to be
contemporary
in the internet so the the internet
exists okay
for sure does story structure make a
movie better or worse
i think it makes the movie better i mean
i think that but again i think that that
structure
does not necessarily have to be you know
that the inciting incident happens here
and then you've got three beats of fun
and games and then you've got this
you know but i think that a story needs
to be working towards something you know
i mean i
do think that we tend to see things in
beginnings middles and ends
you know um and i think as a writer you
should sort of have a sense of where
you're going and where you are in the
story and
the escalation of things of the drama
and the conflict
and obviously i think certain genres
it's more important than others you know
i think if you're doing an
action movie it's very important that
you know you want your biggest
bangs to be last you know you need to be
building up to a big finish so i think
structure is super important there if
you're doing a
you know a small kind of family drama
maybe it's a little less important but i
think that
one way or another i do think that
structure is ultimately a good thing i
just think you need to find the
structure that
resonates most with you and that's what
will work best for you
do you think structure is fairly similar
uh
for novel writing as it is for
screenplays yes and no
it was it was a really hard thing to
wrap my head around when i started
writing novels because my only
experience with structure was screenplay
structures
and you know that question you asked me
earlier about pages you know i would i
would always think in pages as well you
know from a screenplay
and it was really hard to figure out
like well how does this novel
you know i could look in a novel but
there's no like metric to compare it
this book to this script you know like
how do i figure out like
where in the script where this point in
the script would be for this book you
know it's very difficult
and i mean i got really obsessive about
it i mean i even sort of figured out
like okay well my
average screenplay is 105 words so that
translates to
you know uh there's this many words on a
page of
my screenplay so at you know ten
thousand words in the novel i'm at about
page
30 in my screenplay i really kind of
broke it down i don't think that's
necessary
but i needed to do that so that i could
understand it so i could kind of wrap my
head around it
now i think i think i've sort of
internalized it to a little bit so i
think there's still a beginning middle
and end
and i think that some writers
that's all they need and their their
structure isn't super
rigid uh like if you read a stephen king
book he doesn't
he says he doesn't outline and i i can
feel his his books are very loose
you know i'm not saying that's obviously
stephen king i mean it works for him you
know
um but i think the reason why like i
mentioned
many many many reviews i see over and
over on my books they say it feels
cinematic or feels like an action movie
and i believe that that's because i
internalized that
screenplay structure and applied it to
the book and i think that's why it feels
that way
so i think it all depends on what you're
going for and sometimes people
say that as a negative too they'll say
oh you know it didn't really feel like a
book it felt more like a movie and they
mean that
as a negative but i still that still
doesn't bother me because i'm like okay
clearly
they didn't like it it's not for them
but what i'm trying to do is still being
conveyed you know
you